Well I think you can really trace it
back to at least the 1960s,
if not earlier.
What we started to see going on in
American politics in the 1960s and
continuing into the seventies and
eighties was really the disintegration
of the old new deal coalition,
uh,
and alignment that had been,
kind of put together by Franklin
Roosevelt and that sustained the
Democratic Party as the dominant party
in American politics for many years.
Uh,
that coalition consisted of a number of
groups,
uh,
such as white southerners,
a northern white ethnic voters and white
working class voters,
um,
that,
inherently had a little in common with
each other,
particularly when you add in,
um,
the growing representation of African
American voters after the 1960s with the
voting rights act.
Um,
so this coalition was sort of inherently
unstable.
And what we began to see in the 1960s,
uh,
especially after the passage of the
voting rights act and the growth of the
African American electorate was that,
um,
the more conservative elements in that
coalition,
particularly white southerners,
but also,
um,
conservative white ethnic voters began
to move,
uh,
towards the Republicans.
Uh,
we had an ideological realignment that
began,
it didn't happen overnight.
It was a,
it was not something that occurred in a
single election or a couple of
elections.
It was something that took place over
several decades actually.
Uh,
but we gradually began to see these more
conservative voters moving away from the
Democrats and into the Republican camp.
Uh,
and on the other hand,
in response to that,
um,
more moderate to liberal voters,
uh,
who had been aligned with the
Republicans,
especially in parts of the country where
you had a moderate to liberal
republicans like the northeast,
um,
they began to move away from the
Republicans and toward the Democrats as
the Republican party became increasingly
conservative.
So you can see this beginning with
Richard Nixon's southern strategy,
uh,
in 1972,
and continuing with Ronald Reagan's
presidential campaigns.
And then certainly in the 1990s with,
uh,
the,
takeover of the Republican Party in
Congress by a more conservative group of
leaders led by Newt Gingrich.
So essentially what was happening here
was that,
uh,
at the elite level,
we were seeing increasing ideological
polarization and that change began to,
uh,
affect the loyalties of the voters,
and increasingly over time.
And by the time we got to the 1990s,
uh,
it had reached the point where,
um,
the,
uh,
old democratic coalition,
and the Democratic dominance of at least
congress was no longer no longer
existed.
Uh,
and it's really continued even,
uh,
up to the present time.
Uh,
now something else that's been happening
a over this entire time period,
and especially with the last couple of
decades,
it's also playing into this has been,
uh,
the demographic changes taking place in
the electorate and the growing diversity
of the American Electric,
uh,
were nonwhite voters are becoming a
larger and larger share of the
electorate.
Uh,
and particularly of the Democratic
Coalition,
so that by 2008,
when you look at the contributions of
different racial and ethnic groups to
the,
uh,
party coalitions,
you see that,
um,
nonwhites made up over 40% of democratic
voters.
Um,
whereas,
um,
non whites were only about seven or 8%
of Republican voters,
you know,
so this is growing divergence between
the parties,
both in terms of their racial and
ethnic,
uh,
groups that support the parties.
And also in terms of ideology and
issues,
it's the more engaged segment of the
public that really becomes increasingly
polarized because they're the ones who
are really following these debates,
who are really attentive to what is
going on in the congress to the
positions of the parties.
And so they tend to react,
uh,
much more quickly than people who are
just not,
you know,
not paying attention.
But what happens over time is that even
though this process of realignment
really was,
I think,
initiated by political elites,
um,
for strategic reasons.
So you had Republican politicians in
particular who I think saw opportunities
to win over some of these voting groups
that had been traditionally supporting
the Democrats.
Um,
but once the public,
or at least the attentive segment of the
public becomes polarized,
that in turn sort of starts to constrain
the positions of political elites
themselves.
Uh,
and now they have to reflect the views
of the voters who make up their,
uh,
their own base.
And so what we're seeing today is that
it's gotten to the point where the party
leaders and candidates for office are
really kind of constrained to a large
degree by the polarization that exists
among the attentive public.
So if you look,
for example,
at primary voters,
you find that,
you know,
Republican primary voters are really
quite conservative.
By and large Democratic primary voters
tend to be a fairly liberal and
therefore candidates who want to be
successful in politics,
you have to appeal to these primary
voters.
In addition,
um,
there are more and more congressional
districts and even states where one
party is dominant and therefore the key
to success in those types of districts.
And those types of states is again,
just to appeal to the party base and
there's less need to worry about
appealing to voters,
uh,
from the other party.
So political campaigns have become more
about mobilizing the base then about
appealing to the swing voters in the
middle.
If you look back over the course of
American history,
we've been through many periods of
polarization,
uh,
to some extent.
I think,
um,
the period from the 1950s do the 1960s
was unusual in that a degree of partisan
polarization was much less than normal.
Um,
but if you go back and look at American
politics in the 19th century,
uh,
and in much of the early 20th century,
you find that in fact,
you know,
they were very sharp differences between
the parties and very intense conflict
and very overheated rhetoric,
uh,
and really nasty personal attacks,
on even some of the leaders that we've
come to think of as among our greatest,
you know,
presidents,
people like Thomas Jefferson and Abraham
Lincoln were viciously attacked.
Uh,
um,
Franklin Roosevelt certainly was as
well.
So,
um,
in a way this is just sort of normal
politics.
It's really interesting to go back and
of course they didn't have the internet
or cable news or talk radio,
but what they had were pamphlets and a
party newspapers.
And,
um,
if you go back and look at some of those
things,
you know,
um,
as I said,
the,
the attacks were very personal,
very nasty.
Uh,
I mean much worse than anything we've
seen in recent election campaigns.
Oh,
definitely.
I mean,
I think that the changes that have
occurred in,
uh,
the,
in the media have a reinforced this
trend toward polarization,
particularly the proliferation of news
outlets,
uh,
cable news talk radio and the Internet,
which mean that now people have many
more choices about where to get their
political information and they can turn
to a news outlets and information
sources that are,
uh,
you know,
in consistent,
uh,
or reflect their own,
you know,
their own political orientation.
So if you're,
whether you're liberal or Conservative,
you can find,
you know,
media outlets.
You can go to Fox News.
If you're a conservative,
you can go to MSNBC.
If you're liberal.
Uh,
and,
uh,
people no longer rely on,
you know,
a few major network news broadcasts,
um,
to get their information the way they
did,
you know,
40 or 50 years ago.
Well,
I think the problem there is not so much
with polarization as it is with certain
institutions and rules that have
survived from an earlier era when
politics was not so polarized.
Uh,
the prime example of that being the
filibuster in the Senate,
um,
because in the past when there's less
polarization,
the filibuster was used very sparingly.
As the parties have become increasingly
polarized,
we've seen that filibusters have become
routine and almost everything gets
filibustered because it is,
you know,
the only way that the minority party can
exert any influence.
Um,
so I think it is that filibuster role.
They fact that it takes only 41 senators
to effectively block,
uh,
any action on the part of the majority
that is largely responsible for this
sense,
uh,
of,
um,
uh,
you know,
of gridlock.
This feeling that,
that we've been gridlock.
And the reality is that this congress is
actually passed a lot of major
legislation.
Some of it's been quite controversial,
but,
uh,
it's not really the case that it's been
an unproductive congress.
It's just been involved in dealing with
some very controversial issues.
Um,
and on the house side where majority
rule really prevails,
uh,
a great deal of legislation has been
passed.
Some of it has then gotten bogged down
in the Senate.
Um,
and still,
uh,
it's still awaiting action again because
of the filibuster rule primarily.
Well,
I,
you know,
I like to say that,
uh,
we need a certain degree of polarization
that democracy really depends upon,
uh,
having,
a certain degree of polarization,
uh,
so that voters can choose between the
parties based on which set of policies
you really support.
And I think today it's pretty clear.
I think what the parties stand for.
People for the most part,
I think understand the differences
between the democratic and Republican
parties.
Uh,
and they feel that,
um,
there's a lot at stake in these
elections and therefore that tends to,
uh,
increase the level of interest.
Certainly polarization can go too far.
And,
uh,
you know,
in a democratic political system,
it's important that those who,
uh,
are defeated,
have to recognize and accept the
legitimacy of the winners.
And the winners have to,
uh,
understand that,
you know,
those who lost the last election may be
back in power in the future.
Uh,
and what we're seeing now in American
politics is that sometimes the,
the rhetoric I think gets so heated,
uh,
that,
um,
you know,
there's a tendency to sometimes
questioned the legitimacy of the other
side.
Um,
and we've seen this a on both sides that
both among Democrats and Republicans as
a tendency to question the legitimacy of
the,
uh,
of the other party.
And the other side to question the,
um,
the loyalty of the other side,
the patriotism of the other side.
Um,
you know,
uh,
so,
that kind of inflamed rhetoric can
sometimes also lead to threats of
violence,
you know,
and I think that is a very unfortunate.
Um,
so I think while having a clear
differences between the parties is a
good thing.
Uh,
I think that some of the overheated
rhetoric,
uh,
and personal animosity that we've seen
in recent years,
uh,
is really not a desirable,
well I don't think it's polarization is
going to end anytime soon.
Uh,
I think that there are some very
important longterm factors underlying
it.
One of which is the growing in a racial
and ethnic diversity of the,
uh,
electorate,
which is only going to increase.
Uh,
and so as the
racial and ethnic composition of the
party coalitions continues to divert,
um,
I think that that is kind of reinforcing
this trend toward polarization.
We're seeing that on the issue of
immigration for example,
where,
um,
you know,
on the one hand,
I think that,
um,
there are some Republican party leaders
and strategists who realized that that
the party really needs to figure out a
way to reach out to this rapidly growing
voting block of,
you know,
Latinos,
uh,
who are now the largest ethnic group,
largest minority in the country and
within a few years will be the largest
minority in the electorate.
Um,
and you know,
we'll continue to make up a growing
share of the population.
And the electrode over time.
Uh,
but on the other hand,
there's a great deal of pressure from
the conservative Republican base to take
a hard line stance on issues like
immigration.
Um,
so I think,
um,
demographic trends,
are contributing to this polarization.
I think rising education levels are
contributing to it.
We have a better educated electorate,
which also means a larger percentage of
voters who tend to think about politics
in ideological terms,
um,
who can understand these ideological
debates.
And,
uh,
so all that I think is suggest that this
is a,
this is likely to continue for some
time.
Uh,
now eventually,
um,
we may see the leaders of one party or
the other decide that it is in their
interest to try to move back toward the
center.
Um,
particularly if that party feels that
that is the only way to survive.
Um,
we saw that recently in,
in Britain where,
you know,
the Conservative Party after being out
in the wilderness for 13 years,
uh,
found a new leader who decided that it
was necessary to moderate the parties
image.
Um,
so that could happen at some point,
but it's difficult in our system because
in our system,
unlike Britain,
um,
the voters themselves plays such a key
role in selecting the leaders of the
party through the primary elections.
You don't really have,
uh,
something analogous to that in Britain
or in most,
most other countries.
Um,
so leaders aren't necessarily free here
to just,
uh,
adopt new positions,
you know,
Willy Nilly.
Um,
they have to worry about how the voters
who make up their base,
they're going to respond.
So I think that God is going to act as
a,
a pretty strong break on any tendency
toward a moderation in the foreseeable
future.
I think it may lead to some changes in
the larger political system,
particularly in some of the rules and
procedures in the Congress and
especially in the Senate.
The most likely source of change are
place where I think we're likely to see
change will be there.
Because I see the Senate right now as
being a particularly an obstacle,
um,
to,
uh,
you know,
to majority rule,
um,
both because of the filibuster but also
because of the basis of representation
there that every state has two senators,
which means that,
um,
states with a 500,000 people like
Wyoming have two senators and states
with 37 million people like California
has two senators.
Um,
the 20 least populous states have less
people in them than California alone.
So,
uh,
that is,
I think,
uh,
surprises a lot of people,
you know,
we're sort of aware that,
states have different populations,
but that divergence just keeps
increasing,
you know,
and,
uh,
so I think there's going to be some
pressure there,
um,
to,
uh,
at least reform some of the rules of the
Senate,
like the filibuster rule to make it at
least somewhat easier for the majority
to govern because right now,
um,
because of the filibuster,
because you need a superman,
especially after the midterm elections
where the number of Democrats in the
Senate is almost certain to be reduced.
Um,
so we're going to go back to having a
much smaller majority,
um,
you know,
the likelihood of getting 60 votes to
pass anything is going to be,
you know,
almost no.
Well,
you know,
you hear about a ever to hear you hear a
rhetoric along those lines quite
frequently.
When,
um,
President Obama was,
of course,
his first,
uh,
real,
breakthrough,
uh,
was the speech that he gave at the,
as the 2004 Democratic National
Convention where,
you know,
he talked about there being,
there's no,
you know,
red,
there's no there in a red states of
American blue states of America.
There's one United States of America.
And then,
you know,
he used some similar rhetoric during the
2008 presidential campaign.
And John Mccain also,
you know,
talked about wanting to heal these rifts
and,
uh,
appealing to those on the other side.
But,
you know,
as the campaign went on,
we saw that,
uh,
actually the,
the,
the positions of the candidates became
increasingly polarized.
Uh,
and by the end there,
you know,
there was very little of that sort of an
effort to reach across the,
uh,
to the other side.
Um,
because the fact is that,
you know,
the electrode itself is very polarized.
And so,
you know,
we have,
uh,
a very high degree of,
you know,
partisanship.
Uh,
and when it comes to voting,
people tend to vote along party lines.
There's not much crossover voting these
days.
Uh,
and so as the campaign proceeds,
they focus tends to become increasingly
on energizing and mobilizing your own
base.
Okay.
You know,
b,
because there's such a small sliver of
undecided voters left,
uh,
in,
in the middle,
and it's actually very hard to act even
reached those people,
you know,
because they tend to actually be the
least least interested in at least
attentive segment of the,
of the public.
So,
and since the election,
certainly we've seen more of that sort
of back and forth,
you know,
about,
um,
why can't we have more bipartisanship
and each side blaming the other for,
you know,
the lack of bipartisanship.
But fundamentally,
I think it's very difficult to have any
kind of bipartisan cooperation these
days because the differences between the
parties are so great.
Um,
there used to be a lot of members of
Congress in the middle.
You had moderate to conservative
Democrats,
you had moderate to liberal Republicans,
there was a lot of overlap there.
And therefore it was easy to find
coalition partners from the other party.
Now there's no overlap at all between
the parties.
And so to build a bipartisan coalition
is very difficult because you have to,
when you,
when you tried to reach across the,
uh,
the partisan divide,
that divide is very,
very wide.
Uh,
and it means that,
um,
to bring in any significant number of
members from the other party,
you have to actually compromise your
fundamental principles.
Uh,
and that's why I think we're seeing that
that just doesn't happen.
There are a handful of members in the
middle.
Um,
and so,
you know,
you'll see some efforts to reach out to
those few members as we saw in the early
days of the Obama administration when
they were able to win over,
they had three Republican senators who
voted for the stimulus bill and one of
them subsequently switched parties.
Well,
I think this person does exist,
but it's really confined primarily to
the opposition party,
to the supporters of the opposition
party.
Um,
and we saw the same thing really,
um,
during the Bush administration,
particularly the last two years of the
Bush administration.
There were a lot of angry voters out
there,
but the,
at that time they were,
they were almost all democrats who were
upset about things like the war in Iraq,
uh,
about,
um,
the Bush administration's,
you know,
economic and environmental policies and
so on.
Now with a Democratic president and
Congress,
it's the Republicans,
especially the more engaged Republicans
who are angry,
they are angry because they disagree,
you know,
with the Democrats on issues like
healthcare,
uh,
and budgetary priorities and so on.
So,
yes,
I mean,
I think there are angry voters out
there.
I think sometimes it gets a little
overblown,
you know,
because I'm not sure that
voters are angry or overall now than
they have been in the past.
Um,
I think it's just that we're seeing more
visible manifestations of that with
these tea party demonstrations.
Well,
they're not angry anymore because now,
uh,
for the most part,
because you have a democratic president,
um,
now the,
some of them might still not be thrilled
with all of the things the Obama
administration has done.
But by and large,
I think what you find is that there's
been a reversal,
you know,
that,
uh,
you know,
sort of like the,
the anger is gone over from one side to
the other.
Not Right now,
you know,
because again,
it's harder I think for people to get
worked up when,
you know,
they're in the majority,
um,
that especially in midterm elections,
we tend to see that it's the disgruntled
people who are the most active.
We saw that in 2006 where it was really
the Democrats by and large,
who are the most enthusiastic at the
most engaged.
Um,
and now it's the Republicans,
you know,
with a Democrat in the White House.
Uh,
so that's sort of part of the normal
cycle of American politics.
That's what tends to happen in these,
in these midterm elections.
It's just that with increasing
polarization,
you know,
I think what happens now is that these
swings become greater,
um,
and the reaction becomes even stronger.
Well,
I think certainly a,
a,
some incumbents are in danger,
although I think that some of the,
um,
media,
uh,
characterization of the election,
as an anti incumbent wave has been
overblown.
Uh,
the fact is that in all of these primary
elections so far,
only one house incumbent has actually
been defeated.
One,
um,
and two Senate incumbents.
But in both of those cases,
I think there were actually special
reasons behind their losses.
I mean,
Arlen Specter switched parties about a
year before the election and really gave
Democrats very little reason to vote for
him.
Here's a guy who had been a republican,
all of his career Democrats in
Pennsylvania.
We're used to voting against him.
Um,
he switched parties and basically the
rationale,
he gives us that,
well,
I needed to do this to survive.
Um,
so,
you know,
I think there that it had more to do
with,
uh,
the particular circumstances of the
party switching by Arlen Specter.
Um,
and,
um,
you know,
then,
uh,
in the,
the,
the Utah case,
you know,
you had a,
a,
not a primary election,
but a very small,
uh,
party convention dominated by the most
conservative activists in the Republican
Party in Utah,
which is a pretty conservative state to
begin with.
So I just wouldn't want to read too much
into that.
Um,
now there's no question when,
uh,
voters are discontented,
um,
over the economy and the state of the
country that they tend to vote against
the party in power.
And so,
and in addition to the fact that it's a
midterm election and the president's
party almost always,
you know,
loses seats in midterm elections and the
Democrats are in a rather defensive
posture anyway because they've picked up
so many seats in the last two elections,
many of which are actually in Republican
territory.
You know,
so you've got a lot of,
uh,
democratic incumbents running this year
who are representing states and
districts that,
that,
you know,
have usually voted Republican in the
past.
Um,
so my expectation is that the Democrats
will lose a substantial number of seats.
And,
and so,
you know,
quite a few democratic incumbents will
lose,
but that's more a reflection of just the
normal kind of partisan swings that we
see in elections and especially in
midterm elections rather than any
unusual level of voter anger.
And Moreover,
I think it's very,
um,
misleading,
I think to try to read too much into the
results of these primary elections or
special elections that have been taking
place.
Uh,
you know,
I think that is a tendency on the part
of the media often to over-interpret,
you know,
the latest event,
uh,
whatever just happened is always the
most important thing that's ever
happened.
We saw this during the presidential
campaign,
you know,
both the primaries and the general
election campaign.
Um,
Reverend Wright,
you know,
was when that,
when that event happened,
all that was the end of Obama's
candidacy.
Well,
it wasn't,
uh,
and again,
you know,
during the general election campaign,
uh,
all the furor over surrounding the,
choice of Sarah Palin as John Mccain's
running mate,
well,
that turned out to be overblown,
you know,
so I think we're seeing the same thing
this year.
Uh,
every time some new interesting event
takes place,
whether it's an encumbent losing in a
primary,
you know,
or a special election outcome.
The media jump on that and,
and try to read,
you know,
into that some great significance for
what's going to happen in November.
Um,
I think that that is a really overblown.